Well, here we are in my example of a
confusing signifier. It's this door plate thing. Well, actually, I'm
not sure what to call it because this is a
door handle and this, I thought, was something I could
push on to open the door, and I can't open
it. No matter how hard I push it, I can't,
well, it turns out, it's not a door. This is
a wall. A glass wall. And they put this plate
here and I thought I could push on
it and I can't, so that's a confusing signifier.
Now let's look at that for a second. Why is it so? Well, it seems that there's
a lock mechanism here and the lock mechanism,
see inside, is about this big. Well, I think
the designer wanted to have some symmetry so they
made these two plates the same size, but in
so doing so, they have kind of an aesthetic
form there, but they've created a function or a
false signifier that is confusing. So, how might we
make this better? Well, let's see. Let's assume we
want to hide the lock. Maybe we just want
to make this smaller and keep the symmetry here.
So we might make a plate this big. That
would be really too small to put my whole hand
on it. I don't think I would confuse that for a plate. Or, if
I just wanted to hide the lock, maybe I could make something really small, like
that. Either way, it would be a little bit better, because I feel like if
I push this too hard, I might actually do some damage to this glass wall.